if it has come off my body or touched my
body it has value
toenails body hair spit vials earwax the
more they desire you the more empty you
can make their wallet
I'm Rebecca blue I am the professional
goddess and I am known for selling weird
things on the internet I have been in
this industry since I was 18. I was an
adult Entertainer I was a webcam model I
started to consistently get requests
especially when I was webcaming for my
socks and my underwear these are very
normal items in the industry to sell
this used to be like a once a month
thing or a once a week thing until I
discovered more websites that really
focused on selling these products
panties and socks are kind of the ones
that take the cake but it was the
weirder things that I was much more
interested in as gross as it seems I
think we can all relate to stealing our
boyfriend's hoodie there's this pleasure
that comes from that Aroma now I take it
to the next level when it comes to my
toenails or burping in bags and selling
them for money but to me what's grosser
is having to work in a cubicle the menu
starts anywhere from five dollars to 5
500 dollars now if it's one toenail it
might be five if you want to bundle and
save for all ten maybe we'll do 30 bucks
but ultimately you want to ask your
client what their budget is other things
on my menu include body hair spit vials
earwax burping in a bag bath water
crushed up food my trash
Q-tips body wipes used eyelashes
absolutely anything you can think of if
it has come off my body or touched my
body it has value and you need to know
your worth Queens I would never sell my
organs or if it has something to do with
the toilet there are many rules and
regulations at the post office and you
need to be aware of what is allowed on
my good months I make about ten thousand
dollars and I do have slow months where
I make about two thousand dollars but
this business is extremely unpredictable
I think it's really important to view
this as a side hustle because the last
thing you want to do if you are feeling
financially insecure is have to rely on
something that takes so much time and
energy to me my clients and customers
are people who have the courage to
express their needs and I can offer them
a safe place to do that where they're
not shamed I get shamed for what what I
am selling I can only imagine how much
people shame them for what they like or
what they're doing with what they like
but we all have these deep desires and a
full pleasure spectrum that a lot of us
never have a safe place to explore so
not only are they paying for the product
but they are paying for the experience
and the fantasy the more they desire you
the more empty you can make their
wallets
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I went viral when I talked about on Tick
Tock how I sold my contraceptive my IUD
for four figures and yes he has it on
his mantle and I started the series
weird things I saw on the internet I've
now trademarked it and I gained a huge
following of people who were just in awe
of it or intrigued and then a lot of
women who said how can I start this
selling weird things on the Internet
it's kind of like the wild west you know
there are no repercussions if customers
are do you dirty blackmail you stalk you
so you have to be extremely cautious so
when my tick tocks were going viral I
was like I need to warn people if you
want to start this like here's what to
do here's what not to do so I ended up
starting a podcast I wrote a book I have
a beginner ebook series because I
thought if I can succeed we can all
succeed and there is space and room in
this industry for everyone if you are
not someone's cup of tea you will be
someone shot a whiskey if there is
something unique about you you can
capitalize on it a lot so as my
businesses progress my goals are to
create more community and more of a safe
space for the adult industry I feel like
there needs to be a school for this
there needs to be a safe space for us to
really be allies for each other to rely
on each other to have resources so
whether that is a physical space or a
virtual space it's coming
there's not a lot of respect for sex
workers adult entertainers or anyone in
this in this industry we are completely
sexualized whether we are in work or out
of work but it is a job we pay taxes we
categorize expenses we have write-offs
all the things that anyone else in sales
would have I am so fortunate to say that
I am self-made I pay all my own bills
I've invested in my own businesses and
stocks and real estate all from selling
weird things
thank you
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
foreign